(lively music)
(audience applauds)
- What's up, Dublin?
(audience cheers)
(laughs) I'm really
excited to be here.
I have really enjoyed,
this is, first of all,
actually, back to the reference
of that, I've done this a lot,
I've been very blessed
to be able to speak a
whole bunch in the last decade
and I can tell you that this
is a remarkable execution
for a first year event,
and so I think we should
all collectively clap
it up for these fuckers.
(audience applause)
Really good.
Think it worked well.
I'm super humbled to be here.
I really wanna focus
on a couple of things.
I'm gonna frame up this
talk, I decided just now,
'cause I like to improv
it up, in clouds and dirt.
Some of you that pay attention
to me know what the means,
for the rest of
you I'll explain it.
I think almost all of my
success, and when I talk about
my success I wanna make sure,
I'll use this opportunity,
as well, to clear that up.
It's not about how much money
I make, it's not if I actually
buy the New York Jets, my
football team that I'm trying
to buy, it's that I just
genuinely wake up every day
being extremely happy.
I'm an extremely happy guy.
I think the world is
in a much better place
than the majority of people.
I think that I'm an optimist,
I think there's enormous
gifts in being optimistic,
I hate cynicism, I think people
lack perspective, I think
people don't realize the math
between becoming an actual
human being, when you start
understanding four
hundred trillion to one
is the odds that you're
actually sitting in this seat,
it's so intense it's hard,
and I'm completely driven
by gratitude, and so
when I think about my success
as a human, living happy
so that I can do my thing,
I think about it
in clouds and dirt.
And I think about it in
clouds and dirt in my success
of being an
entrepreneur, as well.
And when I understood
the diversity of the audience
watching here and
watching in live streaming,
I thought it was
the right place to go,
because whether you're a
startup founder, or whether
you're an executive or
whether you're an entrepreneur,
or a student, whether you're
18 or 81, the one thing that
has been consistent in success
when I have analyzed it
is this notion of clouds and
dirt, and what I mean by that
is the following.
For example, there's a
lot of marketers in here,
and the reason I believe
that they will not be
macro successful to
their ambitions or their wants
and dreams is because
they're just headline readers.
They're just in
the clouds, right?
They've read the articles,
they've read the books,
they've heard those thesises.
They've heard somebody
say Facebook ads don't work,
say Facebook ads do work.
They've heard people
say Snapchat doesn't matter
anymore cause Instagram
copied the features.
They talk in theory.
They lack being a practitioner.
Others are in the dirt.
They're 100% practitioners,
They know how everything works,
I think of it, really, in
the same way I think about
marketing overall, which
is branding versus sales.
Some people don't do
anything unless they can do
last touch attribution,
conversion math,
and understand what it's worth.
They laugh at the notion
of doing something like
putting a logo on a stadium
or doing a video
for the sake of video,
because they're just
transactional salespeople,
they're math marketers.
Other people like my
clients, the biggest brands
in the world, go
completely the other way,
they only wanna do branding
a stadium and TV commercials,
and they make up
bullshit metrics and reporting
to justify if
it actually worked.
It's the same
way of being a CEO.
I'm in the clouds,
I've gotta run the whole thing,
it's $100 million company.
It's an agency,
800 people, four offices,
it's a lot of work,
I've gotta be up here.
But the thing I pride
myself in, you couldn't imagine
the happiness in my
heart as I stand here knowing
that in the dirt of
practitionership within the
social media environment,
which is where I spend a lot of
my time on right now,
I'm just a better executor
than every
fucking person in here.
And the reason I am is cause
I just devote seven, nine,
14 hours a day to it, I just do.
And the other thing is
I'm not scared, I'm not scared
when there's a new
feature or a new platform.
I don't mind wasting my
time on Marco Polo or Anchor
or Peach or House Party,
because one of them may become
Snapchat or Instagram,
or they may become Vine
or Social Code or Plurk,
it actually doesn't matter
because it actually just
goes right to what's up here
on both sides,
which is the following.
The greatest way to
think about what you're trying
to accomplish is
actually strategy.
The number one thing
that I don't talk about,
even the people
that know me the best,
I rarely talk about the
way I think about strategy.
I elude to it, I do it in
actions, but I don't get here
by accident, I didn't
get here by being funny
or charismatic or
aggressive or cursing,
I did it by work.
One thing I wanna remind
all the young entrepreneurs
in this room is, and
I need to just say this
and I need to say it more
often, especially with the way
so many are rolling,
and I didn't say a word
to the world for 14 years,
I went into my dad's liquor
store, it was a small business,
I grew it from a three to a
$60 million business,
I worked every day,
every weekend,
for 15 hours a day,
and built a
$60 million a year business,
and then talked about
how I did it for 13 years
and prior to that moment.
We live in a world right
now where everybody is just
putting things in
their profile and claiming
to be the part.
And that is an absolute
mistake because the winners
can sniff it out.
You can trick losers.
You can't trick winners.
And not tricking winners
is the biggest vulnerability
that so many young
entrepreneurs have right now.
I wanna explain day
trading attention, it is the one
core move of my career.
When I was six years old and
I tricked my five friends
to stand behind the
lemonade stands, what I did
the whole time was
walk up and down the streets
of New Jersey, sit on
the corner, literally,
I need you to wrap your
head around what I'm saying,
as a six year old child I
thought it was a fun thing to do
to sit for hours at a
time and watch cars drive by
and try to figure out
what tree or telephone post
they would most look at so
I could put a sign up there
for my lemonade.
Basically from the
womb, much like somebody who
had to sing, or like somebody
who had to play football,
I had to follow attention.
When I sold baseball
cards and sports memorabilia
as a 12 and 13-year-old,
I would look at my table
and I would watch how
people would look at it
and I would rearrange
product predicated on
what they would look at.
How many people
here are designers, UI/UX,
raise your hands, anybody?
A couple.
To me, I feel such an
attachment to you guys,
because it's really how
I think about the entire world.
Everything to me
is about attention.
I have no emotion
to the logos down here,
Instagram, Twitter, Snapchat,
Facebook, YouTube, zero,
I'm thrilled whether
it's VR, whether it's AI,
whether it's six other platforms
over the next six years,
I have zero emotion wrapped
up into where I communicate.
What I care about is
where is your attention today,
where is it underpriced,
and where is it overpriced.
Television commercials,
in theory, work.
There's some, there's
probably four people in here
that watch them, right, like
you could get to somebody
with a television commercial.
The problem is
it's historically priced.
It's so overpriced
for the attention.
I could go on
this beautiful building
and do smoke signals.
Somebody inevitably would go
out and look up and see it.
It was probably just
not a good use of my time.
My email open rate in 1996
on WineLibrary.com was 91.1%.
91% of the people on an
e-mail newsletter opened it.
53% of them
clicked Add to Cart button.
That is impossible in a
2017 world 20 years later
because the only thing
that happens with attention,
just so you know,
is there's attention,
and people that
wanna sell to you,
are chasing you
there and they're ruining
the place that you went to.
There's always a new platform,
and it's really
fucking awesome at first.
We love it, right?
No ads, this and that,
and then the ads comes,
and then you all
say, "Oh, fuck Instagram.
"Now that they have ads
I'm gonna go somewhere else."
But you don't.
'Cause you're full of shit.
(audience laughter)
Right?
And then, guys and
gals like me take advantage
of that perfect moment when
it's big enough to matter,
and sell shit, whether that's
to sell a pair of sneakers,
to get you to donate to an NGO,
to get you to vote for me,
whatever it may be.
And we sell you
in that great period
that every
platform has always had,
whether it was
newspaper ads or direct mail,
or television, or Facebook,
Google AdWords for me in 2001.
Guys, I owned the word
wine for five cents a click
before they made it a 10
cent minimum for nine months,
before anybody bid me up.
I built a huge
business on the back of that,
and I had no money.
It was so underpriced
that I took care
of that arbitrage
and I won on it.
And so, what you do,
and this is the number one
piece of advice for
everybody in clouds and dirt,
please make your
strategy around attention.
Nothing else matters.
I don't give a crap
what you do in this room,
you've got to tell me about it
before I do something with it.
And that is our number one job.
I don't care if
you built the greatest
fucking SaaS product
for fucking farmers.
I don't care if your
sneaker is lighter and cooler,
or your coffee tastes better
than anything ever produced.
I don't care if
you're the funniest
fucking influencer of all time.
Before you prove it,
you need to figure out
where the attention is,
you need to deploy it,
and then it needs to convert.
There is a period and
there is always a period
of one to three years where a
platform has that attention,
and it is grossly underpriced,
and it is your job
in this room, to figure out how
to contextually
story tell within it.
It is not Snapchat,
or Facebook's job
to make a
platform for B2B selling.
It is your job to
figure out how to sell
a B2B product
on those platforms.
Got it?
That's the game.
Period, end of story.
That is the macro strategy
of all things in society,
and basically,
for me, it's all I've got.
I really kind of
suck at most things.
But my ability to really
understand where
the attention is,
and then, 'cause that's
the macro, that's the clouds.
That's the thesis,
that's the strategy.
Chase attention,
and day trade it.
The reason I added day trading,
is I realized, "Holy crap,
this stuff changes
"not year by year.
This changes now day by day."
If I was here seven months ago,
one of the things
I might've brought up
in my improving
right now is that,
"Hey, I'm
worried about Instagram."
You know, Snapchat is
growing older by the second,
Facebook's much
younger than you guys think,
and I'm not sure
where Instagram has a spot
over the next year or two.
Then, Instagram makes
seven feature changes,
all of which Snapchat had,
and now my conversation's
completely different
as many of you,
I can see some
faces that follow me,
I'm more bullish on
Instagram than anything.
And I've no emotion of what my
opinion was seven months ago.
People that make
statements and then think
they have to hold on to it
for the rest of their lives
'cause they made it
are going to lose always.
Especially in a world that's
changing as quickly as this.
And so, for me, it's
all about top line strategy.
And so my top line strategy
nine years ago was this;
That this was going to become
the primary device of our lives.
That not only was it
gonna be the remote control
of our lives, but that
this would become the television
and the television
would become the radio.
And so nine years ago,
I basically committed my life,
to understanding that
this was the television,
and that Facebook,
Twitter, Instagram, YouTube,
were the BBC, and CBS,
and NBC, and CNN, and SkyNet,
and I was gonna figure out how
to make the best shows on it.
Whether that was me.
Whether that was Wine Library.
Whether that was
my clients, and I promise you
that that thesis has worked out,
and I implore everybody
here to start thinking
about their lives
in success, right?
From a clouds
and dirt perspective.
I loved the last presentation.
I barely listen to anything.
I consume no content,
and so much of what I
heard as I was getting ready
was so right and
makes me think a lot
about how I was parented,
and how I want to parent.
My macro clouds
in being a parent
is I want my children
to be as happy as I am.
Because I'm real fucking happy.
(audience laughter)
So that's my clouds,
it's simple. Right?
Most parents tie
their own self-esteem
into their
kids' accomplishments.
That's why they put
stickers of what they did
in school, or what
club they're part of.
I don't care if my
kids wanna be entrepreneurs,
not entrepreneurs,
if my daughter wants
to make
paintings out of tomatoes,
she'll get my support 1,000%.
I want to reverse engineer them.
I want to know what
they want to do, right?
That's my macro.
Then my micro is
the details of that.
The actual
practitionership around that.
Like, how much do
tomatoes cost, right?
Like that.
And I believe 98,
99% of this room plays
in the middle
of clouds and dirt.
I believe that the
market plays in the middle.
A, they don't have
top line strategies
and understand
where the world's going,
and B, they get
fancy and they don't want
to get their hands dirty.
Much like my intro
which I appreciate.
The reason I stopped
and took a selfie
and said hello and shook
hands is who the fuck am I?
Do you know what
kind of feeling it is
to have people
admire what you do?
Do you know how nice it is?
Do you know how nice it is
that someone will
DM you and say, "Hey."
Do you understand
what that feels like?
You have to pull
from opposite directions.
Clouds and dirt.
That's called
really big fucking ego,
and really massive humility.
And that's why people
react so differently to me
because it depends on
what snippet they saw.
'Cause they're
either seeing this,
awesomest dude they've ever met,
or this, fuck that motherfucker.
(audience laughter)
what makes me comfortable,
and what I would implore
all of you to think about,
is the clouds and dirt
about how I think about that.
Which is,
I really don't give a shit
about what any one
of you think about me.
That's over here.
Let me come back over here.
It is insane to
me how much I care
about what every single person
in here thinks about me.
That's literally my life.
I literally macro,
clouds, don't give a fuck.
That's how I've
achieved what I wanted.
Most of you are not
doing what you want to do
with your life
because you're worried
about someone else's opinion.
Normally,
your fucked up mom,
or your spouse,
or somebody very close to
you is fucking your shit up.
(audience laughter)
Right, so that's awesome
for me, but on the flip side
in the macro of
me not giving a shit
when somebody leaves one comment
on an Instagram post like,
this guy is a scam artist.
I'm like strategizing
how to fix that like
it's the most important thing
that has ever happened to me.
Pulling from opposite directions
is like a bridge, my friends.
It is not something
that you should be scared of.
Way too many people
think it's a contradiction,
think it's a flaw.
When you define what
true intelligence is,
it is holding
opposite things in your head
and allowing them to push.
I love that
everything is easy to me.
We were having fun
beforehand, I'm like,
what's this thing I'm
doing after my keynote,
and they're laughing, they're
like, you didn't read it?
I'm like, I haven't
read shit in 20 years.
I don't need to be
prepared, I stay in my lane.
The reason I love doing
Q&amp;A is if I don't know
the answer to
your question I'll say
I don't know the
answer to your question.
We are fronting, we are
fronting in our society.
You need to triple down,
quadruple down on who you are
and what you know,
and then you can win.
When people ask me
how do I produce content?
One big breakthrough in
my community was when about
six months ago I said, you
know what, we should document
instead of create.
It opened up so much for
so many when they realized,
wait a minute, right,
you need to be documenting
in your stories or in
your vlog about the journey
of becoming an entrepreneur,
not claiming that you're
a 21-year-old life coach,
and pay me $5,000 a month
and I'll teach you how
to fucking live, fuck you.
(audience laughter)
Documenting versus creating.
Your truth is the only
thing that you will ever
successfully sell.
I love when people think sales
people are shitty, right,
and I agree, except
the top one percent.
The reason I've been so
successful is I only sell
stuff I believe in.
Every wine I ever sold,
every thesis I've ever had,
every startup
I ever invested in.
Do you know how fun it
is to sell something you
fundamentally believe in?
Now, here's what comes along
with the clouds and the dirt
of selling something that
you fundamentally believe in.
From a clouds standpoint,
over two, three, four years,
especially if
you're good, you will win.
The world will come to you.
Plenty of people made
fun of me when I started
an e-commerce website in 1996.
Nobody was gonna buy
wine on the internet.
Shit, in 1996, for all you
youngsters who weren't there,
the internet was a
fad, remember that?
People made fun of me
when I did email marketing
instead of
making a wine catalog.
The hell was email?
It's stupid.
People made fun of me
when I started a YouTube show
a couple of months
after YouTube came out.
What was YouTube?
Where will it
be tomorrow, right?
People definitely
made fun of Twitter.
made fun of Snapchat.
This is what people do, they
fear, they don't take risks,
and so, when I started talking
about documenting versus
creating, I want to
tell you why I did that
and why I think
it's important for
so many of you in this room.
My friends,
whether you like it or not,
whether it fits your
philosophical point of view
of where the world is,
you are a media company
before you are anything else,
and I mean you as a human being.
That's just the
reality of the marketplace.
I you are able to
understand that and realize that
you are a media company, comma,
you're a SaaS
product for farmers,
you're a media company, comma,
you're a salesperson at
Facebook, you're a media, comma,
you've got this startup.
If you can understand
that it changes everything,
it changes the way that
you think about the world.
If you are not talking in
these platforms, my friends,
this it it.
And by the way, this
would be gone one day, too,
and I can't wait to come here
in seven years and be like,
this, fuck you,
this is over, you suck.
(audience laughter)
But this is it, and if you
are not communicating about
what you're trying to
accomplish effectively here,
and contextually,
differently, in every platform
predicated on how the consumer
thinks about the platform
when they're in it.
AKA, when a woman
is on Pinterest
and has aspiration of
shopping and buying, her mind
is in a different place
than when she is on Facebook
keeping up with her
friends and media companies,
and you have to
storytell differently based on
the mindset, the way
you act and think and work
is very different than
when you go on a girl's trip
for the weekend.
Psychology,
reverse engineering,
macro understanding.
This shit isn't
happening by accident.
I didn't make a funny
fucking video and curse twice
and everything
miraculously happened.
Yeah.
(audience laughter)
So it might be time for
me to start putting pressure
on this narrative,
which I enjoy. I like playing
the I'm stupid at everything,
I even did it in this talk.
But I promise you, I'm gonna
end up being way less stupid
than people think
when this is all done.
Because the great
thing about not giving a shit
about what anybody
thinks is very simple.
Let me tell you why
it's very practical for you
to change your
life and start pushing
against that narrative.
One of the two of
you is gonna be right.
Regardless of how you
debate it in your head,
either you're gonna be right
and you're gonna be special
and you're gonna make it,
or your psycho dad is gonna
be right and you're a
lose and you'll never make it
out of this town.
But debating it over
appearance for 30 years
is a fucking waste of time.
What's way more interesting
is to go out and fucking do
and execute and stick it
to people's fucking faces.
Two days ago, and it never
ends, my friends, two days ago
Apple announced it's show,
Planet of the Apps,
it's one of Apple's original
new shows, you can watch it
through Apple Music,
please do, cause I'm in it,
and there's four judges.
World superstar Will.I.Am,
world superstar Jessica Alba,
world superstar Gwyneth Paltrow,
and me.
(audience laughter)
Super cool for me and my family.
Next step in my career,
more top of the line attention,
then they'll google my name,
then they'll go to
launch my stuff, and I'll have
more stuff, and I'll
figure out what to do
with that attention.
But here is the best part I
took away from the announcement.
Lot of articles written
about it, cool, cool, cool,
but one really stood out.
Planet of the Apps is a
new show by Apple with judges
Gwyneth Paltrow, Will.I.Am,
Jessica Alba, and others.
(audience laughter)
- Best day of my life.
(audience laughs)
There is nothing
that makes me happier
than having a
chip on my shoulder.
(audience laughter)
Chips on my shoulder
have been the
bellwether of my career.
First chip was not being able
to speak English in America,
'cause I was an immigrant and
having five and six-year-olds
make fun of you for that.
Great. Love it.
(audience snickers)
Next, is to be 4' 11" your
freshman year of high school.
(audience laughter)
Perfect.
Next is to get D's
and F's in high school
during the era where
education was at its apex,
and entrepreneurship
was at its low,
and having every teacher
and every friend's parent
say that you wouldn't make it.
Fuckin' perfect.
(audience laughter)
And then going into
your dad's liquor business
and saying that
you're not good enough
so you have to go
into your daddy's store.
Love it.
(audience laughter)
And on and on and on.
And with
everything that I've got,
and everything that I'm at,
still I get categorized as,
"And among others."
(audience snickers)
And I promise you,
that's the way
I always want it to be.
No matter what I achieve,
no matter where I go,
being underestimated
is the greatest gift.
When you can make the mind shift
and actually not care.
When you can make the
mind shift and realize
the debate doesn't matter.
Guys, the debate doesn't matter.
What matters is the end result.
What matters is the
legacy that you leave.
What matters is
don't prove it to me,
don't tell it to
me over social media,
show me.
I love that,
and I love that
we're all so blessed
to be living, and
let me remind you,
because there's a lot of media
that tells you otherwise.
Let me just say it because data,
like the last presentation,
is just a funny thing.
We're living in the greatest era
that any human
has ever lived in.
We need to get grateful.
Is there problems? Fuck yes.
But it's all about alternatives.
You want to be growing up
during the era of
the Black fuckin' Plague?
(audience laughter)
You want that?
You think that's fuckin' fun?
Fuck. Sorry, shit
scares the fuck out of me.
It's all about options.
You don't like your job?
Stop fucking crying
and go get another one.
You're sad that you thought
of Uber before they did it?
Nobody gives a fuck,
everybody thought of it.
(audience laughter)
Everybody's fucking complaining.
Let me end with this, and then
I wanna get into our panel,
which I'm excited for.
Let me just end with this,
because you need to
understand what this means.
Complaining.
There are only
two groups of people
that will listen
to you complain.
The three to four loved ones
that are most closest to you,
and they love you so much
they're willing to
listen to your shit,
(audience laughter)
and group number two,
your other loser friends.
(audience laughter)
Stop fucking complaining.
Thank you.
(audience cheers and applauds)
- Thank you very much.
Okay, I'm not
gonna take up much time,
I'll get out of the
way as quick as possible
because we're gonna pick
up with a panel discussing
much of what Gary
was talking about.
The official title of
the panel discussion is,
"How to Harness the
Power of Global Conversation
"through the Various
Channels Social Media Offers."
I suspect a better term maybe,
a day trading for attention,
as Gary put it.
He's gonna come back out,
he's gonna be
joined by Bruce Daisley,
who is EMEA Vice
President for Twitter,
by Kieran Flanagan,
who's VP of Marketing
for HubSpot,
and the moderator
for the panel discussion
is Ross Kingsland, owns
his own creative agency,
and is a
contributor to FAST Company.
So will you
please welcome back Gary,
and welcome
Bruce, Kieran, and Ross.
(indie rock music)
- Want the middle?
- I'm fine here. Thank you, bro.
Long time.
(audience laughter)
- [Ross] Great. Okay, so--
- Is that your actual voice?
Fuck. (audience
and panel laughs)
Alright, thanks for having us.
- Came on yesterday.
- Jesus.
(audience and panel laughs)
- Awesome, awesome talk by Gary.
Really, really important.
Very, very true,
particularly with
where we are with
the world at the moment.
And I think it'd
probably be useful
if we can talk and use your
cloud analogy to start up here
and talk about the way that
social media is being influenced
very, very directly by some
very, very powerful people.
From someone who
obviously has interacted
with social media
and how we use it,
I'd just like to start
by, Gary if you go first,
just getting your thoughts on
how a leader,
political or business,
or otherwise,
should start to
engage social media
if they haven't
been on it before.
- Well look, I think there's
a very specific reason that
when somebody
creates a coup d'etat,
and wants to
overthrow a government,
the first place they
historically have gone
is after the TV and
radio and newspaper.
They've gone after the media.
The media is what
controls our thinking.
The internet
itself has arbitraged out
the traditional media channels.
So the way I think about it is,
it's the single most
important thing in the world.
The reason I think social
media's so funny, is as a word,
and I'm sure you guys are
gonna jump in here and agree,
it's amazing how
some people think of it
as this afterthought,
a sprinkle,
a nice to have, a
clever little thing.
It's a slang term for the
current state of communication
in an internet environment.
And when you think
about what that means,
it's very hard
to underestimate it.
And I do believe that whether
it's Brexit or Donald Trump
or things of that nature,
we are now in the beginning
process of the transition
of people not
thinking about this
as a small little thing anymore.
In the last six months,
I have had more propaganda
organizations reach out to me
than I've had
in the last decade.
People that have an agenda
about changing the perception
of an issue on
a political level,
and now want me to navigate it,
and architect it.
And I've stayed away from it
because these
things are hardcore,
but the tide has changed.
- [Bruce] Yeah,
in terms of advice,
what I'd give to
someone getting going,
I think, truly,
the best way to ever take
in the power of social media
and the way that
social media's working
is to listen first.
Sometimes you can be ten-eerd
if you stride forward and
you try and say something,
and that might be
you try and say something
in the midst of a big news story
that's blowing up around you.
So always listening first
is the most powerful thing.
And I think, as Gary says,
over the last six months
everyone's been reminded
that more and more people
are getting their information
from the device
in their pockets.
More and more people
are forming their opinions
based on that,
and so it's never
been more important
for people to understand
the implications of that.
And for marketers,
and for people here,
to try and channel that
for their own
companies' benefits really.
- [Kieran] Yeah, I think
one of the things
I'm fascinated about in terms of
the power of
social at the moment
is like its role in the U.S.,
even like the
political pre-election
and current political system.
And if you read
some of the articles
of how how much news
is distributed today,
and like it's
very difficult to do.
Checks or not, it
shows you how much reliance
people put in the
information they consume
through social channels.
And I think for any business
rather than think
"Do I have to do social?"
what you are
really trying to do is
communicate with people
where they spend their time.
And so for a business
you are trying to understand
where do my
users spend their time?
How can I communicate
in a way that is
part of their day to day life?
Not a part of, like,
that person just going
I hate this brand
because they are stopping me
from doing the
things I actually love.
So I think that's
the way I interpret how
businesses can kind of
leverage those challenges.
- And Bruce,
obviously over at Twitter,
famously you've got,
had some issues with
loss profit warnings
recently and share price.
We talked a little
bit earlier backstage
but you obviously
can't go into too much
detail about that.
But was that
basically as I understand it
through a lack of
advertising spent.
And I wonder what
the implications we're on
that with a social
media giant such as Twitter,
has it now need to
plateau, as like Gary explains,
as some of the new ones come up,
and just what is
Twitter's thinking on that?
- Yeah I think that's
a good segue actually
from the
previous question because
simultaneously
you're saying social media
and the way we're
consuming news is changing
a pace faster than ever before.
Simultaneously you're saying
actually you might
superficially read stories
that frame our own situation,
Twitter's own situation,
as more
difficult in that context.
And I think actually
that the first is a reminder
that the device in
our pocket, our phones,
are going to be so
fundamental in terms of
how we communicate
and how we connect
with the world.
What we've tried
to do at Twitter,
I think, there's
one mega trend right now
which is this reductive
thinking and people thinking
that a simple answer
is the answer to things.
And I think what
we've done at Twitter is say
for us to achieve
strong user growth,
for us to build
engagement with the product,
that's not a simple
three bullet point list.
So what we've
tried to do is think
okay let's go back to basics.
There's no quick
solution to accelerate
our audience growth.
And we've
changed a hundred things.
And I think the
consequence of that is the,
over the last 12 months,
each successive quarter
we've seen an acceleration
in our audience growth,
daily audience is
growing probably faster
than any time since our IPO.
And so we're in a position where
there wasn't a simple answer
but we've worked on that.
But I think just a
reminder, you know,
we're in an environment where
it's a very competitive world.
People have got
four or five apps
they use on their phone.
I think 90% of the
time that people spend
is on their top three apps.
So we know massive potential
if we get the product right.
If we make people
realize that time is a
compelling narrative,
there's so much news,
if we make people
realize that Twitter is
an exciting
place to get your news,
then we're in a good position.
- [Ross] Gary.
- [Gary] Yeah, listen.
Twitter... (sighs)
Twitter has a very
deep emotion in my heart, right?
I genuinely feel
comfortable in saying this.
As much bravado as I have,
Twitter is a very substantial
reason to why I am
sitting on this stage.
It was the platform
that completely catapulted me
into the tech space.
You know, it's
like my first love.
It's like the first
girl I hooked up with,
it's always
gonna be there, right?
And so, I have a lot of
emotion towards Twitter.
I would tell you,
and Dick Costolo
is probably one of my
favorite human beings on Earth,
let alone somebody
that I've met in tech,
I think Twitter is
an amazing story of
complacency on the product side.
It went five years when
it was the number two player,
and there was no
three, four and five,
where they did nothing.
They did nothing
on the product side.
And I agree with you.
I am really excited
about Twitter, not from
Trump using it and that thing,
but from little subtle
changes to the product.
I mean, you know, when
you look at why Snapchat
and Instagram both,
in however you look at it,
have had good years,
good 18 months,
they change their
products all the time.
There's feature
sets all the time.
And so I think Jack's
energy of product changes
is very important.
But I do think that
we should understand
how special Twitter is.
And let me explain
what I mean by that.
As a business, it's not
going to sound as great,
as a utility, it's
going to sound the best.
Twitter is actually,
actually the only
pure play social
network in the world today,
as it was
defined in the beginning.
It's the only place
where you put out content,
and you consume content,
and you engage with
people at real scale.
If you look at what's going
on with every other platform,
they're content
push out systems.
They're CMSs at scale with some
functionality of
engagement like a blog.
When you look at
Twitter, it is actually
the water cooler of our society.
The problem and
challenge for Twitter is
CMS content push at
scale is good business,
because you're just consuming,
and every fifth time
you consume a commercial.
In the way that people consume
the firehouse of Twitter,
they're not consuming.
Twitter, if you
want ads right now on it,
versus other platforms,
it's just not working
to the math that
Twitter wants it to.
But to their credit,
with some of the
video products,
with some of the stuff,
I'm starting to see an uptick.
And again, much like
the micro conversation
I said of, you know,
I said that Instagram
might be in trouble.
Nothing would
make me happier than
two years from now, wait a
minute, it's about Twitter.
And if you look at 14 to
16 year olds in the U.S.,
there's a huge
spike of Twitter growth.
So that's intriguing.
But I think there's a
lot of feature changes
a lot of shifts,
but I will say this.
Whether it's Twitter,
or it's something else,
the same way there was
MySpace and then Facebook,
there will always
more than anything else
be a need for
that actual product.
The globe needs a water cooler.
We will always have it.
We will always have that.
And I think it does hold a very
special place in the ecosystem.
- [Ross] Kieran,
what are your thoughts
from your perspective?
- [Kieran] Yeah I
think that, I don't have,
I think I agree
with Gary in terms of
it's product development,
right, there just
didn't seem to
iterate on the product,
and you see,
I think one of the things
Snapchat has proven,
and I'm definitely
one of the people
who thought Snapchat
was really fucking
stupid when I first used it.
And now I wear a
pair of spectacles,
it's like, dude,
they can build product.
And I think, but the
thing is, for any platform,
you were right,
it's competitive.
How much room do you
have for a different,
these types of communication
channels in your life?
It's a different
ballgame to pass from
200, 300 million into that
one billion that Facebook has.
And that's a
serious mountain to climb
I think for any of
those types of companies.
- I think an important
point that he just made
that's important for
everybody who's watching is,
everything is stupid,
until it's not.
Right? Like to me that is been
the most fascinating thing
over the last decade
in this space.
None of these platforms,
I mean, 2007, when I invested in
Twitter, it was beyond stupid
because you have to understand
social media
wasn't invented yet.
So forget about Snapchat being
stupid as a new social media
thing, at least we
accepted Facebook and Twitter.
We hadn't even accepted
the form of communication.
So it was like who gives a
shit if you're walking your
dog or eating a pizza?
A lot of people.
(group laugh)
- So Kieran just to kick us
off a nice bit, so one of the
issues, and then for everyone
here, is how do you start to
then develop what you will call
your social media strategy?
Or just your marketing,
digital marketing strategy?
What are the first
steps you would recommend?
- I think it's so, I talked
about this in my talk earlier,
but when, in any kind of,
when you come at it like an
acquisition strategy, or
you're acquiring, you're trying
to acquire an audience or
users for products or services,
like where I always recommend
to start spending their time
is actually talking to potential
customers or customers.
Right it's, you can play
around in data, but I think
actually polling like where
your customers spend their time
and how they purchase products
is one of the best ways you
can build out
different channel maps.
And I think what a lot of
business do is they go, I should
be on all businesses, all
channels at once, and they don't
do any one channel very well.
They just do
everything kind of average.
And typically when you're a
business or a startup, you're
actually gonna scale through
one or two channels, you're
gonna dominate one or two
channels and that's where you're
gonna get your growth from.
You're not gonna grow through
a mixture of being average in
a bunch of different things.
So I think trying to understand
you're dream customer,
where they spend their time
and how they consume,
consume content.
And trying to align your
strategy to be part of their day
and something that they want
to consume, not something like
you're trying to interrupt
them or you're trying to create
basically native content for
the platform that they live in.
- [Ross] Cool, Bruce I think
I know your answer,
but what would it be?
- You know I loved Gary's and
Tony's talk, you know, I spoke
to some film students
last week and, no doubt, in the
group of 100 film students
they'll be one student who uses
all the things available, and
works out how every social
platform from Pinterest,
to YouTube, to Instagram,
to Twitter will work for
them, to make them famous.
And the challenge for all of
us is trying to work out how to
make a platform work, but there
are people who have achieved
outstanding results
on all the platforms.
I think, quite often, we look
for the simple answer, rather
than think about what are we
looking to achieve and looking
for examples of
people doing it well.
And pretty much
every platform, you know,
from Twitter,
but through to Snapchat,
to Pinterest, has people
who are achieving remarkable
results on it.
- [Ross] Yeah, Yeah.
- [Gary] I think the answer is
to actually put in work.
Like there's no fuckin trick,
there's no algorithm.
There's no B2B SaaS product
that's going to help you do it.
Like everybody thinks that
there's some magical thing.
It's quality and quantity.
Because we're living in
supply and demand issues.
To your point, DJ Khaled made
tens of millions of
dollars on Snapchat.
Maybe you didn't.
There are tens of thousands
of people who have made a
million dollars,
million dollars of profit,
through Pinterest.
You're absolutely right.
And so the problem is
people don't want to do work.
Like everybody wants to be an
influencer and get a brand to
pay them $50,000
to take a picture and a selfie
on Instagram, they
don't want to put in the work.
Plus, most
people aren't beautiful,
most people aren't funny,
most people aren't talented.
Like we need to actually
deploy more self-awareness, and
we need to deploy
more understanding of what
we're actually
trying to achieve.
Like everybody's trying to
build the next Twitter, Hubspot,
Facebook, Twitter.
The reality is those
are .001% executions.
Meanwhile, everybody trying
to do that is going to put
themselves out of business,
and then go work at a bank
instead of trying to build a
business that does $284,000
a year, which then allows them
to like, like we completely
lack practicality in this space.
It's like Snapchat or bust.
Meanwhile you're gonna wake up
when we have a macroeconomic
correction, and it isn't as
good as it's been the last
nine years and you're gonna work
at fuckin'
Bank of America, dick.
(audience laughter)
- [Ross] So, from my end,
so like working
with tech companies,
one of the things
we always talk about
is a minimum viable product.
What's the smallest version
that you can do to test, to find
out where you can get traction
with your company,
with your customers,
with your platform,
that you can then develop.
- That's super smart, but as
you know and I know, that's
super hard when
you make three assets.
- Yep, yeah.
- Like the strategy right is
great, build, test, learn,
grow, yes.
But how do you put yourself
in a position where you're
putting out 74 pieces
of content a day
across 31 different platforms?
Like, should I do blogging?
Yes.
Should I do a
video show on YouTube?
Yep.
Should you podcast?
You sure should.
Should I do
infographics on Pinterest?
Mhmmm.
You know like should
I do Instagram stories?
Like people are like, Gary,
Instagram stories
or Snapchat stories?
Both, asshole.
(audience laughter)
Right? I mean your model and
my model break
if they make one video.
- [Ross] Yeah, but everyone
thinks it's gonna be that
one video.
- Right everyone's fuckin'
Dollar Shave Club out here.
- [Ross] Yeah.
- Okay
- Kieran you must get this a
lot where people come to you
and say, we want to
do everything, and then
- Yeah, I think most people
- And they butcher it.
- Like, I get that you should
do everything, but most people
get disheartened when they
try to do everything,
and none of them are successful.
I think if you get into the
habit of being successful on
one, the other
channels are easier to do.
And I think people get into,
they'll go to conferences,
they'll go back, they'll have
this moment where they're just
really anxious and crushed
because they're not doing
anything on
any of these platforms,
and they're trying to
do everything at once.
And they'll have
one video on YouTube,
they'll have a podcast
with one interview.
They'll have some
Tweets and then
they're like,
"Oh, this is exhausting
"I'm just going to quit,
"and go and work
at Bank of America."
And I think that--
- [Gary] Oh and by the way I
think that's right,
and it's because they suck.
Like, like, like,
this is a very important
thing--
- Or they don't have enough,
they don't have the resources
other people have, right,
if you're a team of two or
three people, how do you,
it's harder to do everything.
- Your resource is time.
Stop playing fucking ping pong.
(audience laughter)
No but I mean this and I
think, I'm jumping in because
you're right, but we have
to macro this conversation.
It goes back to your ambition.
- [Kieran] Right.
- Right, you're right.
My ambition is so large
that I have to do all that.
To your point, if your ambition
is to make $81,000 being a
flowers influencer, you
can do that on one platform.
The problem is people's
ambition and strategy maps to
being on everything, and
then they give up after three
months on one thing, like
what do you think this is?
- [Bruce] Yeah I think your
point is exactly right,
because if you try
and shortcut this,
if you don't
understand the platforms,
if you're not using
the platforms on a daily basis,
then you're gonna
try to look for the easy and
someone says well
what's the reason?
But if you understand the
platforms and then you know what
your objective is,
then this makes sense.
- You guys are both
saying the--
- There's multi
there's multimillion
business who grew just
through Facebook.
- You're right.
- That's what I'm saying like
if you dominate one channel,
you can have a bigger
business than $81,000 a year.
Like dominating one
channel is not a bad way to
make a huge business.
- No I actually think he's
exactly right, here's what your
saying that I think is
interesting and it's just worth
the debate, what if your company
could have been worth tens
of millions of dollars if you
put your energy on YouTube
versus Facebook but
you never tasted YouTube.
You don't know if chicken is
your favorite food if you've
only eaten beef.
So I think your not wrong and
I think back to your strategy
of test and learn, the
question becomes do you want to
go out and try all those things
and then find that you're
naturally over indexing on
voice, and doing podcasting.
But the point of this
discussion is so important.
There's a million ways to do it,
there's just not a million
ways that you can do it,
and that's the part that
needs to be figured out.
- Fundamentally I have
a problem, everyone comes
and wants a silver bullet.
Everyone here is looking
for what's Gary
going to tell me,
that I'm going to get
the edge over everyone else.
Just from say,
the future is...
Like Snapchat.
- [Gary] You're so right.
- [Bruce] I used to work at a
publishing firm a long time ago,
10 years ago and I used to
say to them, I used to implore
everyone, you have to sign up
for Facebook and of course,
what happened was
they were making magazines
and they were certain
that these magazines were
understanding exactly
what their readers wanted.
I said, but unless
you're signed up to Facebook,
you can't see what people
are starting to do to compete
and I think it comes down to
that you can't necessarily
fake things.
And there are a lot
of people think, right,
I haven't got the time to
learn how Pinterest works.
I haven't got time to
work out how Twitter works.
So just give me
the bullet points.
And I don't think
that's ever as convincing
as someone who has
deeply tried to understand
and go through that
point where you think its dumb.
You're never going
to be as convincing
if you're trying to fake it.
- [Gary] Do you know how many
people here, have opinions
on Facebook advertising
and have never placed
a fucking Facebook ad?
(audience laughter)
I mean, do people know? I mean,
I'm not sure if it's open to
the Ireland market,
but in the U.S. for sure,
Snapchats open
market of buying filters
in an open place
marketplace is early Twitter,
early Facebook and
early Google Adwords.
You can buy filters for $5
for 20,000 square foot
for an hour. So you
can know that there's
this big high school
football game in Texas
'cause that's religion there
and your brand that
tries to reach high school kids
and you could put a
filter over that school
and you could buy it for $5 and
it's an incredible arbitrage,
but nobody's a practitioner.
They've got opinions on stuff.
Everybody will read
a headline from TechCrunch
or Ad Age or Fast Co.
They'll read something
and they'll be like,
oh, Snapchat is dead.
You don't know what the
fuck you're talking about,
unless you're a practitioner
and even within them,
there's opportunities, right?
Yes, maybe at a macro,
I'm a little bit concerned
about a Twitter ad,
but the reason I threw out,
but in the video product is
even within the macro statement
there's micro opportunities to
expose underpriced attention
and that to me is where
getting your hands dirty
matters so much.
- [Russ] Just quickly, 'cause
we're nearly out of time,
but one of the
questions I get asked a lot is,
"How do you train up?"
Because there's,
like, two elements
to mastering social media.
There's the skill, and
actually knowing how to do it,
what to do, and there's
also the communications style
that you have, that you
portray across that is your
persona that comes
across in social media.
Bruce, you can
start if you'd just like.
What would be your
tips for people here
and those listening on
how to start that journey?
Like, two practical steps?
- [Bruce] On a personal level,
how to--
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Bruce] So, what you're
asking, how to create
your own voice on
social media, is that it?
Okay, look, a lot of
people talk about authenticity,
and it's sort
of become so tired.
I think, you know, the
interesting thing is, like,
start with what
you want to accomplish.
I use social media principally
to talk about pop music,
and I work at a
place where a lot of people
at Twitter, when a
bit of news comes out,
they all tweet out
the press release on it,
and I'm not
interested in following that.
For me, I don't use
Twitter as a B2B tool,
but other people do,
so principally, you know,
something like Twitter is,
it's about consuming
what's happening right now.
So for me,
a new pop song
drops on Friday morning,
and that's what
I'm interested in.
But what you tend to
find, and back to what we've
been talking about here, is
that some people will come in
and they'll post
things on social media,
and it might be they're
trying to be an
influencer LinkedIn, or they're
trying to rebrand themselves,
and it feels unconvincing,
because they're trying
to shoehorn some
opinions about programmatic
into their Facebook feed,
and it's just uncomfortable.
So, just knowing
what you want to do,
or knowing why you're doing it,
sends, like, a
pretty good idea to me.
Sometimes, curiosity's
the reason to do it, right?
You know, I've
just started podcasting.
I've started podcasting,
firstly, because I'm just really
curious about the
experience, how it works,
the platforms, so
starting with curiosity's
probably the right thing.
The idea of us all
trying to present a more honest,
nuanced version of
ourselves is great,
as long as you've
got nuances and depth
that people are gonna be
able to explore, I think.
- [Russ] Kieran, obviously, your
Twitter handle is searchbrat.
- Yeah, I need to change it.
Doesn't go down well, and it
means something else in the U.S.
I think, to jump
right on, that one thing
I'm passionate about
is something Gary said,
in that everyone in this space
should be a practitioner.
I think that's, you never have
an excuse not to be able to
try things.
So, like an example, last night,
I was up building, like, a
chat bot for Facebook Messenger
through a
platform called Chatfuel,
'cause Facebook
are about to launch ads
that allow you to send
paid media straight into your
messenger bot, right,
and it's so easy
to spin up a page,
have a simple chat
bot, put it on Reddit,
get some traffic in,
start to send things into it,
so if you want to know
about something in that space,
spend, like, a couple of
thousand dollars and go do it.
If you're
ignorant in this space,
then it's just
the wrong place to be.
- [Russ] Yeah, right, you can't
outsource success, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Gary] I know
we're sidetracking,
but I wanna build on that,
'cause it was
such a fun statement.
Everybody here should
be trying to figure out
how to do an Alexa
skill for their business.
I'm working on one right
now that I'm gonna launch,
and it's just, you know,
people's morning routines.
I'm trying to debate if
I'm gonna do a motivational
statement of the day,
or a tip on business,
like, what people
don't understand
is this is all
about beachfront property.
You either buy it
right before Malibu
becomes the
biggest beach in the world
and you bought it
right on the beach
and it's worth a trillion.
You look at the early pioneers
on Twitter, blogging, search.
People think trying something
new is a waste of time,
at times, and I do love where
you're going with depth,
by the way, but you gotta
taste it just to be dangerous,
because when you hit it,
and you're good at it,
and if you're lucky
enough that you picked Snapchat
instead of SocialCam,
and it becomes huge,
you can really change your life.
The upside's enormous.
As far as your question,
I just think the
truth always plays out.
When I started talking
about business on Twitter,
every single
comment in 2009 was,
"Shut your
fucking mouth, wine boy.
"Stay in your lane."
but what they didn't
know was that was my truth.
Long before I became the wine
guy on YouTube and Twitter,
I was a business man,
and I think if it's your truth,
this goes back to the joke
I made about 21-year-old
life coaches,
if you talk about the journey
of trying to
become a successful,
there's a very big
difference between being
an entrepreneur and a
successful entrepreneur.
I can say that
I'm a football player.
Doesn't mean I'm
gonna get paid to do it.
And so, I think the truth, like,
you truly like that
music, I think it's unbelievably
exciting for me,
it feels warm in my heart
that the thing
I've seen consistently,
analyzing this every
second of my breathing day
for the last decade, has been
whatever your truth may be,
as long as it is
actually your truth,
you will always over-index.
And people told me
to not curse on stage,
you know, my
agents who booked, like,
"Stop cursing on stage, 'cause
we're losing so much money."
I'm like, I can't.
I have to be me, and
wherever the chips fall,
and I think for everybody,
A, it's fun, 'cause it's easier,
and B, audiences
are smart to your point.
You can smell when that
person wants to put their
agenda through, and
so I think the truth,
which is a very exciting answer
to this question,
the truth is undefeated.
- [Russ] Well, I think that's a
very good place to finish,
and I'd like to thank
Gary, Bruce, and Kieran
for taking the time, and
for you for bearing with me
with my ridiculous
voice, so thank you very much.
(audience cheering
and applauding)
- Nice to meet you.
Nice to meet you, man.
(synthesized music)